why are we even going to this um because
it's a hot cool movie premiere why would
we not go I thought my first premiere
would be for a movie that I was actually
in I'm gonna get one of those red carpet
picks with a Getty image Watermark sent
it to all my Ohio friends you still talk
to them starting tonight hopefully
that is a very funny Helena York as book
as book rather do back in the hit series
is called the other two so it follows
Brooke and her brother Carrie an
aspiring actor as they are constantly
overshadowed by the fame of their talk
show host mom and their teen pop star
brother so in this upcoming third season
Brooke is still balancing her career as
a manager to her mom and her brother her
love life and surviving in good old New
York City all while attempting to have
it all you know how that goes in this
preview Brooke rather reacts to her
boyfriend Lance becoming what we all
call A do-gooder
you know just FYI you're not that great
I bet all your friends at work wouldn't
be so quick to like dab with you if they
knew that you
never clean the sink like this
Fork that's been sitting in here since
God knows when we're living in Philthy
you
is going on but look at the boyfriend's
face Elena York joins us first on CBS
mornings good morning and
congratulations to you thank you so much
this seems like such a fun character
because people have described uh Brooke
your character as a hot mess no filter
but you say she's actually just bold I
think that's my way of making myself
feel better about my own hot destitute
I'm like I'm just bold I'm not a mess
but she doesn't have a filter though
Brooke and I think that's what makes her
so fun to play yeah I think that that's
a hard role for you to do no filter
Brooke yeah it's very hard it's real
stress I deserve an Oscar for how much
of a stretch
um no and I think that that's why people
relate to her is that it's sort of she's
saying the things that maybe we're all
thinking so you identify her with her
and the the show actually wrote
mannerisms of your own in the real world
into the character is that how it works
yeah it's humility
um to see them put on page the
manifestation of my delightful
personality at times because they
probably see things and when you first
read the script you're like wait am I
really like this I think a little bit
it's also you this season we take a lot
of really big swings and it's sort of
really out there there's like borders on
surrealism and so to know that they have
faith in us to make this feel grounded
and real in a way is um flattering I
guess you said that this show has
changed your perspective on what success
means to you how so
um it's funny it's like you know right
now I feel like I'm in an episode of it
like I'm on CBS with you guys being like
please watch my show love me love me
um you know and I think that that is
something that just always starts to
bleed in and you have this image of
yourself doing it and you're like oh my
God I'm doing the thing I'm doing it
um and I think for six as far as success
goes so much of what we do is like
wrapped up in what other people think
about us and I became a mom recently and
you just sort of what's what's important
what's your day-to-day what grounds you
in your life you know you did Elena
become a mom recently a new mom Vlad
became a new dad yes
congratulations she says her baby is the
cutest baby in the world
Bar None sorry Vlad I mean I gotta take
umbrage to that I know you're a guest in
our house but I mean okay sorry
insects eat 30. you're like I will eat
you I know sometimes I don't want to go
to jail so I won't but it's changed you
how being a mother change your
perspective on life and things yeah and
like your time I think your time is
worth so much and where and how you
spend it oh look at this it's so
valuable yeah see edible I actually went
to Pittsburgh to bring him home to visit
my mother-in-law and my family and I got
I was like you introduce them to people
and I left and I saw these pictures she
told me here's a meeting with my friends
and I was like where are his pants and
she had taken his pants off to show off
his little leg chunks to everybody so I
left him with the cannibal
also a Broadway girl too though Helena
we should talk about that yes I've been
on Broadway a couple times I went to
school for musical theater I was a dork
I was saying that I saw you on in
Bullets Over Broadway which I you know I
love the film and so I thought oh this
is going to be and you just told me it
closed pretty quickly but I was there
thank you so much for making it yeah I
also did a show called American Psycho
but it was it's just it's a totally
different schedule it's a different life
it's really tough that ho week you don't
have a weekend it's wild you guys
understand hard schedule I mean yes we
do Mom on the show Molly Shannon uh did
she give you any good pieces of advice
in the real world as kind of a stage mom
well that's what's been amazing about
working with Molly is that she's got two
kids herself and just sort of leading by
example of how much she prioritizes her
kids how much she fights to be with her
kids and it's hard as an actor and you
asked me about success about uh you know
what is important what you make time for
and you know just seeing this person who
I admire so much and how much she can
have this wonderful career and be a mom
it's like you sort of think sometimes as
an actress you like blow into a balloon
and like float away in some motherhood
but you know I think that I'm not I
think like she's been amazing to me and
like as an example to me it is possible
we just all we're balancing we're
juggling there isn't a one-size-fits all
you got to figure out what works best
for you yeah thank you please know we're
cheering you on the show is great
congratulations
thank you so much guys we're very
sincere here you're not one of the other
two
the third season of the other two debuts
on HBO Max starting next Thursday you're
watching CBS mornings we always thank
you for that we'll be right back